[Musique]
martin
quoi vous vous aimez le foot est un pays
où les filles jouent au foot on va faire
un match de foot féminin des comics
teint
mon père adorait le foot on au stade
tous les week-ends pour écouter
catherine nicole faire un brushing est
ce que je fais pas de brushing c'est
naturel ces travaux le coach c'est moi
qu'il faudrait écouter je suis prêt à
sacrifier alors là pas du tout
l'entraîneur n'a pas de relations avec
ses joueuses
vous aimez parler puisque vous aimez le
football
emmanuel quelqu'un son jeu et un poteau
droit
oui alors l'admets pas
alors c'est qui les gonzesses vous avez
de l'or au bout des pieds avec votre
talent mon sens de l'entreprise on va
aller très très loin et regarder quand
votre nom ressort bien là je vois je
vois tout à faire ma propre femme m'a
dit qu'elle voudrait bien joué il ne
peut pas y avoir deux féminins
footballeur qu'est ce que ça peut vous
faire quand on joue au foot
c'est vous qui décidez si on est en
droit d'être sur un terrain alors que
vous êtes planqué derrière vos bureaux
on va changer de tactique on va changer
les mentalités
on va avoir des licences une vraie
reconnaissance
on va avoir toutes les autres filles qui
vont nous suivre
nous battrons jusqu'au bout pour jouer
au football comme les garçons c'est une
déclaration au coeur je prend tous les
risques
je me casse alors on abandonne ce soir
on est depuis hier non leur faut aller
jusqu'au midi
vous êtes formidables et croyez moi j'en
ai fait des photos de foot elle vit en
plein jour
[Musique]